BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello.
Welcome to this week's episode
of Between Two Markers with
Paul Saxman, also known as
Google Developer office hours
or Google Maps Developer
office hours.
This week, I'm joined with two
very special guests from
Sydney, Luke Mahe and
Chris Broadfoot.
And they're going to talk about
More Than a Map, the
inner awesomeness of More Than
a Map, because there's some
really cool things going on--
I don't know what you want
to say, underneath the--
I'm sorry?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Behind
the scenes?
PAUL SAXMAN: Behind
the scenes.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Under the map.
PAUL SAXMAN: Under the map, that
we think developers will
really be interested in.
Before we go into the More Than
a Map, though, we got a
couple of public service
announcements.
One is that if you guys have any
questions along the way,
definitely post them
on YouTube.
I'm going to be monitoring the
YouTube channel for comments.
And we'll try to answer those
questions and get some answers
for you guys.
And the other thing is
if you guys haven't
heard about it yet--
hopefully you have-- but there's
the Google Places API
Developers challenge
going on right now.
And what we're doing is we're
trying to get developers to
work with their communities to
build mapping applications
that support their communities
and also highlight some uses
of the Google Places API.
If you're interested in the
challenge, just go to
developers.googl
e.com/places/challenge.
And that'll get you to
the landing page.
We'll show you the page
in just a second.
From there, we have lots of
information about the
timeline, types of apps we're
looking for, rules and
regulations, that
type of thing.
Get you going there.
The news about it, though, is
that the challenge is closing
for submissions on October 31.
So you have just over two weeks
or three weeks to get
your submissions in so that
we can review it.
We're also having public
voting for the
People's Choice Award.
That's actually going
to start November 1.
So we pushed it forward a couple
of weeks to get a few
more submissions in before
we open that up.
So definitely check
out the website.
This will bring it up.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Prizes,
as well?
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
The prizes are pretty cool.
If you take a look at the site,
the prizes are actually
tickets to Google I/O and I
think a $3,500 stipend to get
you here and keep you happy
while you're here if I/O
doesn't keep you happy enough.
And what else was it?
There was--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I can have a
look over on the website.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's true
for the judged awards.
So we have judges that
are actually--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: People's Choice
is two I/O tickets per
team as well.
PAUL SAXMAN: So a lot of
opportunities to win--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, and
you get dinner with us.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh,
dinner with us?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Dinner
with the Google Maps
and Places API team.
I didn't agree to that.
LUKE MAHE: That's better
than going to I/O.
PAUL SAXMAN: Maybe.
Yeah.
Especially probably
all expenses paid.
So we'll try to take
you someplace nice.
Definitely.
So check it out.
Check the website out.
And get your submissions in
in the next few weeks.
And we're looking forward
to seeing them.
And with that, why don't we
get into More Than a Map?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Sounds good.
PAUL SAXMAN: So you guys don't
need any introduction besides
what I gave.
Luke, you're our technical lead
in developer relations
down in Sydney.
Chris, you're technical
guy extraordinaire
working on the Maps API.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So
we launched this--
was it Tuesday last week?
It was
LUKE MAHE: Tuesday.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So if you haven't seen it yet,
head over to morethanamap.com.
And you'll see something
like this.
It's got a whole bunch of cool
demos which we'll show off in
a second and some developer
stories that
you can go and watch.
So these are guys that
are using the Maps
API to its full potential.
PAUL SAXMAN: So one sentence
or less-- why did
we launch this site?
So what's our--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: To show people
all the cool things
they can do with the Maps API.
You can really enhance your
location-based app
using the Maps API--
LUKE MAHE: --and do more than
just put a map on your site.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
We see a lot of maps that are
just a base Google Map and a
marker, which is great.
It's good to see.
But here we're showcasing
some of the--
I wouldn't say less-used
features, but the more
valuable features
of the Maps API.
So we've got some satellite
imagery, Street View, which is
one of Google's unique features
of Maps, places data,
directions.
And we've got some really cool
data visualization demos.
So Luke and I built out most
of the site from a
design from an agency.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, Upperquad
did some really
cool designs for us.
And we took that and
built with it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
We really wanted to make this
site blazingly fast.
So you'll notice that as you
click around, it's quite fast
to load the demos in and out.
And all the pages load
really quickly.
And this is because it's
all a single-page site.
So do you want to talk a bit
about how we did that?
LUKE MAHE: We created a little
MVC framework just to bind all
the pages together.
And what we mainly concentrated
on was using one
map throughout the whole site.
So we don't create a new map
every time we change the demo
or anything like that.
We just share the same map
object around so we don't have
to create a new map
every single time.
It's really cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: So how many views
do you have based on that one
map load, or actually
one page load?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: There's
about 20 demos or so.
You could view all 20 demos
and only use the one map.
Another good thing about this
is you've only used one map
load of your 25,000 a day
to do your whole site.
Generally, you'd only need
one map per visitor.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's
a worthy tidbit.
Somebody that's, let's say,
doing a travel site and they
want to do some advanced search
capabilities or give
you the function where you
want to say, go back and
refine my search.
You don't want them to actually
go back out of your
map, do all that work, and then
go back into your map
because that's another load.
So using some techniques that
you guys did, they could
theoretically just--
one map load for one user,
basically, or one user visit.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And it's not
only just that you use fewer
map loads, but it's also a
nicer user experience.
So for example, if I
go over to the data
visualization demos--
we have a flights demo--
the map loads in.
But if I switch over to the
earthquakes demo, the map's
still there.
The tiles haven't moved.
And this is just because we're
using the same viewport.
PAUL SAXMAN: How's the
bandwidth on that?
You have to load all the assets
for all these pages in
advance, or--?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
So because it's one page, we
load everything up front, but
then we cache it for
a long time.
But because we're not refreshing
the page every
single time we change anything,
we don't have to
reload all the HTML
[? and do all that ?] again.
PAUL SAXMAN: Is it noticeable
if you're on a low bandwidth
connection?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
You'll take a little bit more of
a hit at the start because
we load more.
But then the rest of the
experience is really slick.
So we figured that was a bit of
a nicer experience just to
load a little bit slower at the
start but then to have it
better [? going on ?]
with the rest.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So if I jump
into the page source, you can
see here that there's only
one script tag--
oh, sorry, there's three
script tags.
There's the +1 button, the
Maps API, and this thing
called app bundle.
And this actually bundles in
a whole bunch of different
JavaScript.
So you can see here at the
top there's jQuery.
And as I scroll down, there's
underscore JS.
So this is a library
for directing URLs.
I think it's called director.
This is a jQuery scroll
wheel plug-in.
And then just below, it's all
of our More Than a Map code.
So this actually compiles down
to something quite small
because we've used all
of these libraries.
We could probably make it even
smaller if we minified jQuery
and everything to only include
the functions we use.
But we figured it's small
enough and fast enough.
PAUL SAXMAN: So what are
some of the other--
you mentioned jQuery.
What are some of the other
libraries you guys pulled in?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we used
underscore JS, which is a
whole bunch of utility
functions.
LUKE MAHE: And we mainly used
that for binding so our code
was a lot nicer.
So we didn't have all these
anonymous functions
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And also,
there's a handy [? Each ?]
and map function.
So these are basically things
that are in your browser's
JavaScripts, like
map and filter.
We used it for cross-browser
compatibility.
LUKE MAHE: And then the other
one was director.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Director.
Actually, I can show
you quickly.
This is the flatiron director.
So I think this comes
from nodejitsu.
It seems like it's designed for
server side using Node.js.
But we used it on the client
side and it has--
you basically set
up your routes.
So we might have slash demos
goes to a demo handler, slash
developer stories goes to
the developer stories
handler, and so on.
So this is a really nice way to
have this really decoupled
way of navigating the site.
So we didn't really have to
write any binding code for
links on the page or
anything like that.
LUKE MAHE: Then it also handled
a lot of the nice
stuff of doing pushState
for us.
So it would actually update
the URL without having to
reload the whole page.
But then for older browsers, it
would do a hash tag and use
that as the URL instead.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Actually, I can
show you some of the code.
PAUL SAXMAN: So it
makes it easy--
people can link directly to
actually one of these.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
So we can have a URL
that make sense.
And then people can
share that.
Chris is going to
show the code.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this
is our app controller.
So this basically handles
all of the binding
of the whole app.
And you can see down here,
down below, we
set up a new router.
And we set up a whole
bunch of routes.
So anything under slash demos
goes to a function called
showDemo, developer stories.
And then there's just a general
page handler that just
handles, for example, the Learn
More page, which doesn't
really do anything particularly
special.
PAUL SAXMAN: So any server-side
processing?
Are you guys serving
up data or--
LUKE MAHE: Well, we got a couple
of JSON files, but
they're static.
PAUL SAXMAN: Static files.
LUKE MAHE: Stuff like the
flights data, the population
demos data.
But everything else is a static
HTML page, static
JavaScript, so we can
cache it for ages.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: The only
notable thing is that since
we're using pushState and it's a
one-page site, if you send a
link to your friend, say, to a
particular demo, then we need
to handle the entry to
a particular page.
So we do this by serving
up the same HTML to
every single page.
And then the router will go and
figure out where to put
the initial page load.
LUKE MAHE: And then the way we
did our demo views and our MVC
framework was every demo knows
how to bootstrap itself from
the start to the end.
But if it gets [? given ?]
that loads itself halfway
through, it
knows how to get there.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
So then in terms of hosting,
what did you guys--
I think I already know
the answer, but--
LUKE MAHE: It's sitting
on App Engine.
PAUL SAXMAN: App Engine?
But you're--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: App Engine was
great for serving static
files as well.
I think we had about 150 loads
to our JavaScript over the
whole day, which was
amazing for--
LUKE MAHE: Everything
was just cached.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
It wouldn't matter how many page
views we had, it would've
still served about 150,
200 requests.
So I think it was actually quite
cheap to serve the whole
app because it was all
out of public caches.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
So what percentage, roughly,
of your MVC
framework and maps code?
LUKE MAHE: Mainly, it was in
apps because each one is an
individual demo that does stuff
that's really different.
So the MVC code we made was
just [? designed ?] to be
really, really small and
lightweight that just did what
we want it to, which was
essentially just load a demo
with a map, whether it be normal
maps or Street View,
and then [? initiate ?]
its demo.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We designed the
framework so that we could
add demos easily and quickly.
I wouldn't say that the
framework code is small, but
it's lightweight and
really flexible.
PAUL SAXMAN: So where would
developers go to replicate
what you guys did?
LUKE MAHE: Ours is quite unique
to what we wanted
because ours is about a map.
We took some caveats with
knowing that we're going to be
dealing with a map.
So some stuff like knowing
that we're passing in map
objects and options for that
and reading through those
rather than just being a
standard, any sort of object,
MVC framework.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
I mean, if I were to do it
again, I probably would have
taken some time to learn
AngularJS and see whether that
would suit something
like this.
But we're trying to get this
out the door and just work
with what we know.
And it's sort of nice
being able to reckon
with all of the code.
If you use a library like
Angular, there's so many
moving parts that if you don't
know the library very well, it
probably would have
slowed us down.
Even using the director library,
which is quite small,
we still had to step through
the code to figure out some
bugs and figure out
what's going on.
For example, if I look
at the setup JS
file, there's a little--
I would maybe call it a hack.
But if the browser doesn't
have history support like
older versions of IE and the
user navigated from a single
page, then we'd have to redirect
to a hash slash URL
so that the director library
would still route it properly.
LUKE MAHE: And also then they
don't end up with a long URL
slash or hash another
long URL.
PAUL SAXMAN: So AngularJS,
probably a good place to start
looking if you want to replicate
this kind of one
map, multiple views--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
I think so.
PAUL SAXMAN: --framework.
And then developers look
at the code for the
More Than a Map site.
It's probably going to be a
little hairy, just because
you're using compiled--
LUKE MAHE: It's all compiled,
so it's going to be
interesting to read if you feel
like viewing the source.
But I think we're going
to try and open
source a couple of demos.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
that would be nice.
PAUL SAXMAN: So can you show us
your favorite piece of code
in the entire thing?
LUKE MAHE: I think my favorite
piece of code would be the
flights demo because it's
a lot of flights.
And we're actually using
polylines with the new symbols
on polylines.
And what we did instead of just
having a constant loop
that loops through every single
polyline and then moves
the plane a little bit, we put
every single line in its own
animation frame.
So the line just animated
itself.
And then when it got to the end
of its animation cycle,
just cleared out the animation
frame for itself and
then just moved on.
And we found that the
performance with that was
really great compared to just
constantly looping through an
array of every single
line that you
currently have active.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I think the
reason for that is we were
doing as much work as possible
within each frame.
But if a particular plane didn't
make that frame, then
it would just go into
the next frame.
So as there's more and more
planes, it doesn't get less
smooth, but the planes might
jump slightly more each time
instead of--
only some planes would
jump instead of
all of them, I suppose.
And the map is still
quite responsive.
PAUL SAXMAN: And you're also
using symbols here, right?
Marker symbols?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, we use
symbols on polylines.
PAUL SAXMAN: So you have a
vector-based plane and things--
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
I loaded up Illustrator and
drew a little plane.
And it's just a single
SVG path--
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Export to SVG.
PAUL SAXMAN: The thing I really
liked about this demo,
too, is you used--
what did you call it again?
So it's not a direct
line, right?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
We're using geodesic lines so
the planes fly on the curve.
PAUL SAXMAN: And since you're
using the symbols, it actually
adjusts its orientation
as it flies, which is
a really cool effect.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So if we look
at the code for that one, it's
flights demo.
So you can see a little bit
of our framework here.
We have a base demo class.
So the flights demo just
bootstraps itself, calls up to
the demo constructor.
It sets a whole bunch
of options.
So we've got the map style
as zoom and center.
And then basically, when the
flights demo loads, a function
called Init is called.
And that's just on the
first load only.
So we load in the data.
And if we look at the Load Data
function, we use getJSON
from jQuery.
And once that's finished,
we call the Load
Data Complete function.
And you can see here that we're
using the underscore
library to bind the function.
So if you knew you were working
with one browser, you
could just use the function
[INAUDIBLE]
Bind that's built
into JavaScript.
But again, cross-browser
compatibility.
And then once the data is
finished loading, Load Data
Complete is called.
And the Start function
is called.
And do you want to talk about
what happens here
when Start is called?
LUKE MAHE: So firstly, we just
take a copy of the array.
So that way, if someone wants
to run the demo again, we
don't get in the JSON file
again [? parsing ?]
it.
And then we just loop through.
We set the time.
And then--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So Set Map Time
is the interesting part.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
There is a magic number to
convert from the time number
we have to what the time of
the actual flight was.
And then we basically just loop
through all the flights
that we have in that block
of time, create a
new animation frame.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I think
Add Flight is the most
interesting part here.
LUKE MAHE: So we have
the start and we
have the end locations.
That way, we can find
the distance.
And just to be nice, we decided
that every plane flies
at 950 kilometers an hour
because it just made sense.
And that way, everything
just flowed well--
which, apparently, is the
average flying speed.
And so then we create
a symbol.
And then depending on whether
it's flying into London or out
of London, we set its color.
Then here, we have a little
function that
says Animate Plane.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this
is probably the
most interesting part.
Animate Plane gets called
every frame when Request
Animation Frame gets
called for it.
It might miss a frame
sometimes.
If the plane's in flight, then
we just move the icon.
Once it reaches the destination,
it fades out.
Actually, it stays there for--
LUKE MAHE: It stays there for
a little bit and fades out.
So you can see here, if
it's greater than
100, we set its opacity.
And then we start fading
out a bit.
And then when it gets to 120,
we get rid of that polyline.
And we don't call the
animation frame.
PAUL SAXMAN: So all this fading
is part of the markers--
LUKE MAHE: We're just setting
the opacity just to make it
look a bit nicer.
The planes don't just
disappear as
soon as they got there.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So if you want to do
visualizations like this,
definitely check out symbols
on polylines.
I'll just quickly show
the earthquakes demo
once that loads in.
So this actually uses symbols
again, but symbols on markers.
So because the symbols
aren't animating,
it's just in a marker.
And again, we use Request
Animation Frame for each
earthquake.
And once the quake has
disappeared, then the
functions just disappear.
This doesn't get called again.
PAUL SAXMAN: And the marker is
for people that aren't really
familiar with them.
They're basically like vector
graphics, right?
But you're defining it
in JSON or some kind
of JavaScript notation?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So
it's an SVG path.
It's not actually rendered
using SVG.
Usually, it's rendered
using Canvas.
But you define it using
an SVG path.
And then you can set a fill
color, a stroke color, and
stroke weight as well.
And scale, of course,
and rotation.
LUKE MAHE: And opacity.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yes,
and opacity.
So it's quite flexible.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
Chris, did you have any
code you wanted--
are you also a big
fan of the--?
LUKE MAHE: He likes
the earthquakes.
That's because I built flights
and he built earthquakes.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I do like
the earthquakes, don't I?
LUKE MAHE: We have this
little battle going.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Although I
think the population demo was
the one that captured more
of the audience--
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, so
the heat maps?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: --than
the ones I built.
And I don't know why.
I think it's probably
because it restarts.
We traveled through
from 1950 to 2025.
And after that, it just fades
out and then restarts.
So I think people left it
up on their screen.
LUKE MAHE: People just sat
there and watched it.
It'd be cool if it
went backwards.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: What
else is cool?
PAUL SAXMAN: So this is
obviously using the heat maps.
So you've loaded all the
heat map data for--
did you have to actually
condense the data to get--?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I
think it came from--
it might have been World
Health Organization.
I can't remember--
some public data set.
It was just all the different
years and different countries.
And then I just interpolate
between the years that we
actually have data.
PAUL SAXMAN: So a very valuable
data set and not a
lot of manipulation to
get it in a map.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Exactly.
PAUL SAXMAN: Kind of
a story there.
Good.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Do you
want to talk about--
so we have this cool developer
stories page that fills up the
whole screen.
And as you scroll down, it
moves to the next slide.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
This was kind of cool.
We originally did it with scroll
bars and it was just a
bunch of [? divs ?]
on a page.
But then our designer thought
it would be cool not to have
scroll bars and to use the
scroll wheel to just scroll
sections at a time.
And this was fun because the
Magic Mouse is an interesting
thing to play with.
Normal scroll wheels,
you get a value of
negative one or one.
But the Magic Mouse accelerates
and decelerates.
So you get, depending on how
fast someone's scrolled, you
get a number between negative
50 and positive 50.
And it goes up and down and
keeps calling your function.
So we had to do some
interesting things.
If you scrolled, set a value and
time out to clear that if
you're no longer scrolling.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: This would
actually be a really good
thing for someone to
write a library
for and test it properly.
Because we only had a variety
of mice to test it against.
LUKE MAHE: It wasn't until our
designer says, like, I scroll
and it just goes the
entire page.
PAUL SAXMAN: I can attest.
I use one.
And most websites don't
do it right.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Should
we look at some of
the code for that?
LUKE MAHE: I don't know.
PAUL SAXMAN: We're actually
getting close to time.
LUKE MAHE: This was
kind of cool.
So you can click on the circles
and we just animated,
scrolled down to the bottom.
And same thing with
the Magic Mouse.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And again, you
can see the URL changes.
It seems like it's all on one
page, but the URL still
updates so that people can
hotlink it to their friends.
LUKE MAHE: So they can send a
link directly to that video in
that section, which is nice.
As you're scrolling down, even
though the page isn't
updating, the URL
at the top is.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, I should've
talked about
analytics as well.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, right.
LUKE MAHE: That's cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: Because you only
have one page load--
LUKE MAHE: We have
one page load.
So what we did was we have one
listener on the whole site for
any [? A tag ?].
And we just capture that event
and then handle the routing
ourselves and also handle the
analytics tracking ourselves.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So whenever
the user navigates, we call
this Log URL function that just
goes and gets the path
from the router.
So even if people aren't on
a HTML5 history supported
browser, the page views still
tracked really nicely.
So we had really, really great
analytics for this site.
So Log URL's changed, called
on from the app
controller's functions.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
So I think maybe we'll
wrap up with that.
Thanks for flying up to--
LUKE MAHE: Yes, we came
here just for this.
PAUL SAXMAN: These guys are
actually here for--
we're having a team meeting--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Shindig.
PAUL SAXMAN: Shindig, yeah.
I won't say what it is going
to be on the air, but it
should be fun.
Thanks for giving
the demo, guys.
This is pretty awesome stuff.
Definitely we'll see
what we can share.
Like you mentioned, we're going
to share some demos out
for developers at some point.
LUKE MAHE: If anyone has
any questions, feel
free to email us.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
I took a look.
No questions right now.
Let me take one more
with reload.
I have to triple check and make
sure I had commenting on.
Yeah, I know I did.
If you guys have any questions
after you watch this, post it
in the comments on YouTube.
And we'll try to get
back to you guys.
With that, thanks
for joining us.
And we'll catch you guys in
about a week, probably--
I know that's a Sydney week, but
you guys might be off the
hook because we're here today.
Anyways, we'll be either in
Sydney or Mountain View in
about a week.
Thanks again, and see
you guys later.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Thanks, Paul.
[MUSIC PLAYING]